climate change is happening faster than
even scientists had thought possible
scorching heat waves ferocious storms
torrential downpours this is the issue
of our time there will be climate
refugees even here in Britain
nothing like this has ever happened
before we're evidently chapter 1 but
it's not too late to change our future
[Music]
gas oil and coal the fossil fuels that
have powered our world for 200 years
they brought us financial wealth but now
we're realizing with a catastrophic cost
carbon dioxide it blankets the earth
trapping heat without it the planet
would be as cold as a freezer but the
more carbon dioxide there is the more
than planet cooks the level has been
soaring since the start of the
Industrial Revolution it's now the
highest in more than three million years
each of us in Britain produces seven and
a half tonnes of greenhouse gases every
year convert that to a volume and it
would fill a balloon this size now just
imagine one of these for every man woman
and child in the country just filling
the sky in global terms with pretty
average countries like the US and China
produce more less industrialized nations
nowhere near as much but overall the
world is producing the equivalent of 160
balloons of carbon dioxide every second
it's a massive concern really because
we've just not seen changes like this
since humans have been around we've
evolved and what's around us has evolved
slowly with the atmosphere changing and
now it's changing so fast
we're not adapted to this we're already
feeling the effects in the UK nineteen
of the twenty warmest years on record
have all been this century within 50
years we could suffer lethal heat waves
every other summer worldwide thousands
of species could disappear there have
been five mass extinctions over Earth's
long history the one you know about is
the asteroid that wiped out the
dinosaurs the rest that was climate
change even humans will be driven from
their homes the United Nations predicts
there will be 200 million climate
refugees by 2050 and some of those will
be
this is Fairborn North Wales barely
above sea level only a high wall stops
it from the flooding but the council
won't defend the Victorian resort as sea
levels rise shoring them up will be too
expensive beautiful Stuart has lived
here for 40 years
but he and 850 other residents have been
told by the council they will have to
evacuate their homes abandoned to the
waves and it'll be sometime in the next
26 years nothing like this has ever
happened before we're evidently chapter
one a bit terrible terrible thing for
the people in the village to actually
lose their home it's such a such a
beautiful area where could you move to
in the country that's like this it'd be
such a shame such a shame you
decommission a factory or a nuclear
power station you don't decommission a
village because as humans live in the
village Fairborn will be the first of
many communities around the UK
surrendered to the sea if water levels
rise by a meter by the end of the
century as predicted sea defences would
have to be extended around the coast by
hundreds of miles this is going to be a
nationwide problem government advisers
reckon that by the 2080s one and a half
million homes in England will be
vulnerable to coastal flooding 100
thousand could slide into the sea and
that's not the end of it gas terminals
power stations up to 1,000 potentially
toxic landfill sites could be swallowed
up by the waves the villagers have been
told there is no compensation for their
climate blight they may even have to pay
to have their houses demolished
despite the warnings we're burning
fossil fuels like there is no tomorrow
and that's raised the planet's average
temperature by one degree even the most
sober scientists are alarmed the risks
go up over time and the sooner we act
the cheaper it is to solve the problem
and the easier it is to solve the
problem every year we put off doing
anything about climate change we lose
two years in the amount of time we've
got left Concordia University created
the climate clock and it shows we have a
little over 15 years before we burn the
fossil fuels that would take us to 1.5
degrees it's a critical threshold set by
United Nations scientists any warmer and
coral reefs will virtually disappear
there's a good chance the Arctic would
be ice-free in summer and yields of some
of the most important food crops would
slump it's a threat to national security
an urgency that isn't lost on the
government's chief scientist it's his
job to advise the new prime minister
well my message is that this is the
issue of our time the Science and
Technology in terms of the solutions to
reducing emissions are pretty clear
across most of the areas you need to
look at and so that's not primarily a
scientific problem it's primarily an
implementation problem and therefore it
becomes essentially a governmental and
political issue as to how quickly an
effective you want to do it we talk
about one and a half to three degrees of
global warming to have very serious
consequences it's hard to comprehend how
even small rises in temperature can have
such dramatic impacts on the planet but
what happens to the human body is a good
metaphor the lab is heated to 36 degrees
my core temperature quickly climbs it's
amazing hearing the effects on the human
body and they're very similar to how we
climate scientists talk about small
temperature increases to the planet but
as you can experience right now even
these small Nachman 3 degrees for your
body can make a big difference rain
thirty minutes later my body temperature
has risen to degrees I was laying down a
6.5 NASPA once carbon dioxide is in that
atmosphere it sticks around for hundreds
even millions of years even if we manage
to stop emitting greenhouse gases if we
manage to level them off the climate
similar to your body wouldn't stabilize
right away one of the most serious
things from that is the Seas sea levels
would continue to rise hundreds of years
as that heat made its way into the
oceans
I can't safely continue I do feel a bit
sick I can cool down the planet will
take longer Britain has taken a lead on
climate change it's the first country to
have a legal target to reduce greenhouse
gases we have the sixth biggest capacity
in the world for wind power ten thousand
turbines now generate almost 1/5 of our
electricity Britain's greenhouse gas
emissions have fallen 43 percent in less
than 30 years without really changing
our day-to-day lives but to stop climate
change we need to reduce them all the
way to zero and that will be far more
challenging it'll mean replacing gas
boilers in 25 million homes with green
alternatives that's 1 million a year if
we start tomorrow we'll also have to run
every car lorry bus and train on clean
electricity or hydrogen and plant 1.5
billion trees to suck up the remaining
carbon dioxide it's a huge undertaking
and the government hasn't said how it
will do it and its own advisers warned
it's already missing existing weaker
targets I am concerned we absolutely
recommend a tougher target because the
science demands it but unless there is a
plan alongside that to meet it when the
opsi ambition in every sector of the
economy in every department of
government at every layer of government
that target is unachievable the public
will also need convincing
research by sky data shows 2/3 of people
are worried about climate change but
fewer seem to be convinced about the
need
change lifestyles just half say we need
to fly less and only 1/3 think we need
to cut back on meat to reduce our carbon
footprint the government has set a
target of reducing greenhouse gases to
Net Zero by 2050 but to get there it
will almost certainly have to offer us
incentives yet subsidies for solar power
have been stopped and discounts for
driving electric have been reduced
it doesn't actually require too much of
a leap to think that we can fix this
problem the next stage of the journey
involves a different set of things where
we are going to have to engage people
properly in the discussion of how we get
from here to the air I don't think
there's anything to be scared of about
that but while the wider public is split
on the need for action young people seem
united by a generational injustice you
guys feel good Oprah and politicians
should be looking at you and thinking
what's going to happen when these guys
start voting miles Allen helped to write
the United Nations report that made the
case for limiting global warming to 1.5
degrees but the voice of youth could be
as powerful as any number of scientific
papers the costs of climate change are
being dumped on this generation and they
should be absolutely up in arms about
that because it is totally unfair but he
hears too many young people disheartened
by the task ahead maybe I don't want to
have children because I don't want to
raise them in its place where they have
to always
about cleaning up after pasteurization
look we need you and your kids to fix
the problem so I would say absolutely
don't give up on humanity in that way
and it's also said you know and the
problem can be fixed a lot of the
deadlines things you read online shock
you and you sort of go into an overdrive
panic and you can't tell him I'll read
something to tell my mom be like oh we
need to do this we need to do that maybe
it's good to hear the fact that even if
we don't hit this deadline we need if we
don't act today and it changes
straightaway that we still got time the
UN scientists say we need to have carbon
dioxide emissions by 2030 to stand any
chance of meeting the global warming
target but that's widely misconstrued as
that being fewer than 12 years left to
save the planet five degrees we will
start to lose things
we'll start to lose things irreparable
but there will still be a planet worth
saving so I worry about that 12 years or
else you got to be clear what the or
else means we're losing stuff already
we're going to carry on losing more the
longer we carry on using the atmosphere
as a waste um but it's never too late to
turn it around
remember that balloon of carbon dioxide
we produce each year
well our lifestyles our choices our
voices can make a difference it's worked
with plastic pollution public concern
has driven businesses and governments to
respond the scale and the urgency of
climate change is even greater
what happens next is in humanity's hands
a climate apocalypse is far from
inevitable we know what we need to do
we've got the technology what we lack is
the political will
[Music]
you